inspiration I'm paraphrasing is either
conscious and you're aware of where you
heard of it or subconscious and you
don't realize it and I think so many
people who say the original let's say
don't realize that the inspiration is
subconscious and if you could
consciously fill yourself with like more
inspiration whether that's like I'm
Gonna Keep a folder of all the best
YouTube thumbnails which is what I do
you know when I see something I click on
I'm like why did I click on that and I
have a folder which I'm happy to share
with anyone if they want to DM me or
like like I I'd be curious to see like
what's in your swipe file if I I'm like
whoa that's an amazing intro hook
um literally do a screen recording put
that in the folder of my best intros yes
and then when I come to sit down do a
video or I'm sitting down with my
editing team I'm like all right how do
we want to approach this like what are
the different inspiration I like to say
Don't just take from one take from many
and then uh give credit and then put
your own spin on it and that's kind of
like how you Channel Beyonce and there's
a lot more to it but that's in a
nutshell and I think you you said
something like but she's not doing copy
and paste yeah yeah yeah she's doing
copy and taste yeah so my money line
that I was like okay how do I like
summarize this uh it's like okay so
everybody's talking about copy and paste
she's all about copy with taste and so
copy and paste is like you steal from
One Source you give no credit uh like uh
you don't lift the art you just like
replicate it copy with taste is like you
share the credit you you adapt from
multiple sources not just one and you
kind of elevate it in a new way and just
leave it out in the world for somebody
else to copy with taste so yeah you know
what's kind of funny is there's some
critics of like
The Tick Tock and shorts remix there's
some critics so maybe the react format
and how much echoing it can feel like
there is on YouTube but there's a
documentary called Everything is a remix
really good we'll actually link to it I
think they eventually it was on Vimeo
originally and I think that we could put
it we'll put in the show notes it's very
worth your time but it will take even
people like Quentin Tarantino and scene
from scene of like Kill Bill they'll
show you exact scenes in other films
that are just structured the same way
like shot for shot almost of course it's
original because it's his own thing in
the ways but he's inspired by
cinematography from these other films
that were inspiration for him and it's
bringing it into his work so why maybe
things are faster now and certainly
there's some where people are just doing
copy and paste and they're not copying
with taste but I think that this is not
even a new thing I think the art form of
remixing making it original but
consuming a lot of Divergent content and
then synthesizing it
is a very powerful Insight that a lot of
us can learn from two things number one
I've had too much coffee today number
two if you have not seen our free master
class yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class